de la mobilité propre et de l'automobile
plus électrique ce sont les propositions
du candidat la république en marche à la
présidence de la région ile de france
laurent saint martin pour sa campagne il
était en déplacement lundi 29 mars au
campus des services de l'automobile et
des mobilités de guyancourt sacoche
toutes les cases de ma campagne des
enjeux de formation des enjeux de
transition écologique c'est d'abord un
exercice d'écouté qui est le mien
aujourd'hui mais aussi celui de
confronter mes propositions
nous avons parlé avec l'ensemble des
formateurs de la pertinence justement
d'accompagner encore davantage via la
prime à la conversion via notamment tous
les outils que la région demain pourrait
faire en plus pour pouvoir non seulement
aidé la formation professionnelle mais
aussi aider dans le sens de la filière
automobile probablement le candidat a
donc visité l'ensemble du campus qui
forme aux métiers de l'automobile mais
également de la moto ou encore du vélo
une visite appréciée par la directrice
qui souhaite que sa filière ne soit pas
oubliée dans ces élections régionales
c'est une période
qui suscite en fait un ce type de
rencontre est pour nous c'est important
en fait que le monde politique soient
conscients de nos enjeux comprennent
également les investissements des
collectivités territoriales et bas nous
accompagne sur l'ensemble de nos projets
pour nous c'est important de faire
entendre la voix des services
automobiles et on ajoute désormais le
plus souvent possible de la mobilité
parce que le véhicule automobile a
souvent mauvaise presse alors même qu'on
peut aujourd'hui développer tout ce qui
est mobilité douce
et puis véhicules hybrides rechargeables
électriques etc
malgré la crise sanitaire le campus des
services de l'automobile et des
mobilités continuent de former ces
apprentis et alternant une formation
d'autant plus importante au vu des
enjeux futurs de cette filière